[Music]
Hey ladies it's Jonah here so but edge
has most of us want that don't we
the good news is with regular exercising
you can firm and tone them up which will
enhance and give them a fuller
appearance so I'm gonna share with you
seven of my favorite exercises we'll do
each exercise for 45 seconds long with
15 seconds rest in between what you'll
need is a pair of dumbbells I would say
between 4 to 5 kilos each so get
everybody warmed up and let's work on
your butt and also your chest muscle so
ladies if you're a beginner you can do
these exercises without any weights I'm
lifting 5 kilos each okay so the first
workout is going to be a narrow squat
with a reverse lunge so we're gonna
alternate okay narrow squat with a
reverse lunge the goal is to keep your
body and your knees bent and low all the
time so do not stand tall ready two
seconds
let's go narrow squat with a reverse
lunge okay give me one narrow squat with
a reverse lunge good
so stay low narrow squat lunge and
narrow squat the reason why you want to
stay low is for you to really work on
your thighs and also your butt muscles
low right good do not rush the workout
go low and reverse lunge left and right
one on each side
good keep going narrow than your knees
narrow and lunch you should really feel
your butt muscles and your lik muscles
firing up keep going
four more seconds last one give me one
more and wrap it up good next workout I
want you to stand wide it's going to be
a wide squat okay toes pointed back and
I wanted to hold the weights in between
okay so what I want you to do is I want
you to squat down and
shabbat back good that's it ready let's
go squat down and push your butt back
and stand up squeeze squat down
push and squeeze your butt good down and
squeeze good so when you come up be
conscious and really squeeze your glute
muscles low and squeeze so do not bend
forward but squat low and up and squeeze
good go low up and squeeze all right so
point your toes out squeeze your gluts
really engage those muscles and you
should also feel on your inner thighs
good very good give me a few more give
me at least one more okay
and good now we want to work on the mat
so grab your mat okay and we want to do
few chest exercises the first is going
to be a chess bridge press okay so lie
on the floor good lift your butt up I
want you to squeeze a bud and give me
chest press good so elbows bent push up
squeeze the butt hold the pots and push
good
so dumbbell straight up band 90 degrees
push-up so this workout will really work
on your butt and also your chest because
you're lifting your butt off of the
floor
keep going stay strong give me a few
more up down and up squeeze okay
and get your abs do not drop your butt
right now
go keep going do more push it squeeze
and good drop it down let's get onto
some cruise shops all right so on to
your push-ups
I want you to do alternate proof shop so
that means going starting in the middle
okay but let's start on the left side go
down alternate go on to your right so
what you're doing is you're targeting
the left chest and also the right chest
one at a time if you're a beginner again
remember you can always drop down onto
your knees and start on your knees very
good keep going and as you progress you
know the drill
get into your toes and keep alternating
keep your elbows wide bring your chest
close to the floor and give me a nice
push up I know most of us hate free
shops but push-ups I would say it's one
of the best workout for your chest
muscles and you do need any weights rest
it down right now let's face up
lie back it down bring both dumbbells
okay and place them just right on your
hips okay what we want to do is a bridge
so bring your back down bring it up and
squeeze good so bring it down and bring
it up and squeeze very good small
movement but it will really engage your
butt muscles again beginners you can't
do this exercise without any weights if
you want to challenge yourself then put
more weights and lift heavier squeeze
for two counts bring it back down up
squeeze engage those gluts back down and
up good fifteen seconds left what I want
to do is to swing your butt left to the
right to the left to the right to the
left and to the right okay so target and
hit
ich glue good no let's get back up grab
your dumbbells
okay the next workout is going to be an
elbow squeeze all right with a shoulder
press that's it okay so squeeze and feel
your chest ready let's go elbows squeeze
control for your chest and up all right
good so working on your chest muscle
it's not just about your chest okay you
got to tone up the entire upper body
hence we want to add the shoulder press
good so squeeze your chest push up and
feel that you're working on your
shoulders nice and control open up and
push very good you should be sweating
because I am and you should really feel
on your chest and also your shoulders
keep going you have 15 seconds left
squeeze for your chest nice and control
up and squeeze and up last few more give
me two more one up last one squeeze and
up good final workout let's find your
balance all right so it's going to be a
single leg deadlift with a kick back
okay nice and control on your right leg
first and that will swap ready let's go
single leg deadlift nice and up squeeze
your glutes okay so when you are trying
to find a balance that's when you have
to engage your core and really work on
your glutes and if you're struggling
just look at one point all right
it's not about rushing to work out it's
about engaging your muscles good kick
back as high up as you can as far as you
can and up good give me a few more finer
balance and gauge suck in your belly
type in your core nice keep going
kick back as low as you can good and now
let's keep going go it down every time
you go challenge yourself to go slightly
lower and feel it under good very good
all right
swap side ok so shake your right leg out
left leg now
ready let's find your balance and
remember to keep your knees slightly
bent all right and kick back let's go
push and up you will feel that you are
more balanced on one side keep going and
up so look at one point to find your
balance if you're struggling you can
always tap down alright tap down and
bring me back so down up tap and bring
it back good as you progress just
balance on one side good keep going kick
back and up
very good keep pushing whew last workout
and you will get a one-minute break five
more seconds give me one more as low as
you can up and rest it out drop your
weights take a one-minute break keep
yourself hydrated drink some water
breathe and we want to do round two
[Music]
you have 15 seconds left this is round 2
okay you know all the exercises I want
you to give me your best effort and
really work on your glutes and also your
chest so let's start with narrow squat
okay and a reverse lunge good so
remember to always stay low let's go to
narrow squat and reverse lunge always
stay low
bend your knees go low and give me a
deeper narrow squat go low squeeze push
up with the Hughes for your glutes down
push on with the heels and feel your
glutes good even for your lunch go low
good let your knee almost touch the
floor good down low and lunch very good
keep your knees bent
don't come up right now I know your legs
are burning I knew your glutes are on
fire but that is the goal keep going
narrow squat and down give me two more
okay one on each side Bend and last one
narrow squat and shake it out good now
stand white all right wide squat and
really squeeze your gluts so weights in
the middle all right so pointed toes out
and remember to squat no right let's go
down up and squeeze your gluts good down
when your knees point your toes out down
through your inner thighs and squeeze
very good so really squeeze and feel
those glute muscles good then wide okay
keep your chest up keep your body
upright and squeeze till your hips
slightly at the top good keep going
you're halfway there bring the weights
right in the center remember to also
pace your breathing good squeeze push up
push your back back squeeze push your
back back go low good give me at least
two more down up one more
ah very good we're going down onto the
floor okay let's lie down and I want you
to do bridge with chest press so lift
your butt up okay squeeze your butt and
give your butt and almost 90 degree
let's go chest up press it straight open
up squeeze your chest press relax and
touch the elbow onto the floor and press
up and again always remember to engage
your abs and your core okay do not let
it drop keep it tight
suck it in squeeze your glutes and
squeeze the chest muscle nice and
control very good control down press up
nice and control and press up keep going
this exercise again you're killing two
birds with one stone
alright good squeeze the glutes press
your chest nice relax the shoulders use
and engage your chest muscles give me
last one more squeeze tighten your abs
and very good and now let's get up into
alternate crew shops okay we do
dumbbells down and onto the mat choose
your option either on your toes or on
your knees all right ready stop in the
center we are going left but let's go
left down good right down chest close to
the floor look straight down and push up
with your chest muscles up good strong
control down strong up very nice I can
suck your belly in keep your body in a
straight line as you progress beginners
get onto your toes okay no pressure it's
all about starting very good few chest
muscles feel your shoulders as well keep
going few more you got this this is
round number two give me one more on
each side down up one more okay down and
back down hip bridge grab your dumbbells
alright lie back down flat onto the
floor place them just on your hips
alright bring your back down push up
squeeze your gluts down and up
so really secure your dumbbells firmly
good squeeze and up very good control
and up so do not rest your gluts on the
floor kiss squeeze engage very good I
remember the last 15 seconds we want to
sway your butt from the left to the
right keep going
give me two more up down and up ready
let your left right left right
so really engage to the left and the
right cheek keep going don't drop right
now keep it high keep it lifted squeeze
squeeze squeeze right let's get back up
okay the next workout is going to be an
elbow squeeze with show the press all
right ready
four seconds left let's go start strong
all right let's give me a nice strong
elbow squeeze and press up very good
nice and control do not drop the weights
I know this is tougher because you're
sure the muscles are somewhat smaller so
press it up straight and strong good so
squeeze it and who should have very good
so always remember to keep your body
straight your body in line so do not
arch or do not hunched okay so squeeze
and press up very good squeeze for your
chest control up nice and controlled
down squeeze open up 90 degrees press up
good few more up press last one give you
at least one more after this okay this
is your second round so at least one
more press and rest it out good last
workout the most dreaded one single leg
bit liver case so find your balance
start on your right side bend your knees
slightly look at one point okay ready if
you can't do the kickback that's fine
right let's go
down and good squeeze your glutes down
nice and controlled tighten your abs
tight inner core and up don't rush the
workout control slowly extend your leg
to a kickback good nice and controlled
kick back and up okay
every time you go try to go slightly
deeper and keep your chest up so do not
hunch your back look at one point very
good go deeper up tighten and squeeze
extend and up good down rich balance and
mass oh my god that wasn't easy next leg
okay
left side final final workout I promise
you and you will get a good rest right
shake your right leg out left side okay
forward bend your knees let's go down
start slow and up once you find a
balance that's when you can add the kick
back good up and let's go try extend
your right leg kick back slightly up
squeeze very good if you're struggling
what you can do is gently tap and bring
it back back down tap and bring it back
good
as you progress find your balance
very good keep back control look at one
point very nice few more okay you have
five seconds left
give me one last one with a kick
well done drop your dumbbells that's the
end of your workout to turn up on your
butt and also your chest muscles okay
for best results remember to do this
workout at least two to three times
weekly and just take it at your own pace
find your rhythm as you progress you can
of course increase the set to 3 sets and
combine this with total body workout as
well as cardio workout remember if your
cubicle system trust me you will see
results all right so don't give up keep
it consistent and let me know how you
get on in the comments below like this
video share this video subscribe to my
youtube channel if you haven't yet done
it and also turn on your notification
button so that you will get notified
every time I upload a new workout video
recipes and even fitness and nutritional
tips I hope your sweaty lot of rest